[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Anne
gellineck guten Abend zu einem ganz
besonderen heute journal die Wahllokale
in Polen sind seit 45 Minuten
geschlossen und es sieht nach der ersten
Prognose so aus als ob die
europafreundliche Opposition unter
Donald Tusk die Wahlen gewonnen hat die
regierende nationalpopulistische
peacepartei ist zwar stärkste Fraktion
geworden hat aber die absolute mer
verfehlt es geht um nicht weniger als um
eine Richtungsentscheidung in unserem
Nachbarland eine die auch Europa
verändern könnte wir berichten gleich
ausführlich aus Warschau vorher aber
schauen wir nach Israel in ein Land das
noch immer unter dem Schock der
Greueltaten der Hamas steht und das
jetzt eine massive bodenoperation in
Gaza vorbereitet christian sieas hat
dieses studiopult hier verlassen um uns
die Lage in Israel noch näher zu bringen
und damit direkt zu Dir Christian guten
Abend nach Tel
Aviv guten Abend Anne guten Abend ihnen
allen live aus Tel Aviv wo das
verheißungsvolle Funkeln der Skyline
überdeckt dass dies eine tiefgroffene
Stadt ist ein ins Mark getroffenes Land
egal mit wem man hier spricht die
historischen Vergleiche rauben einem den
Atem unser 11 September heißt es da der
entscheidendste Moment seit der
Staatsgründung Erinnerungen an den
Holocaust
grund genug heute von hier zu berichten
weil diese zesur weit über Israel
hinausgeht und der gesamte naheosten am
Rand eines katastrophalen flächenbrands
steht dessen Folgen uns auch in
Deutschland auf lange Zeit beschäftigen
werden wir beginnen heute Abend mit der
aktuellen Situation in Gaza gerade
einmal 70 km entfernt von hier direkt
hinter mir südlich wo Israels Armee
massiv bombardiert und über die Hälfte
der gesamten Bevölkerung aufgefordert
hat ihre Wohnungen zu verlassen wir
werden Hamas zerschlagen kündigt Israels
premier heute an L walport mit
mehr die erste Sitzung des
notstandskabinetts beginnt heute in
Israel mit einer schweigeminutee für
1300 Opfer des hamasterrors das Land
trauert und Israel rüstet sich für einen
Gegenschlag noch ist der Befehl zum
Einmarsch nicht erfolgt die Luftangriffe
auf Gaza dauern an und feuert weiter
Raketen zurück wie hier im
südisraelischen stot das Auswärtige Amt
hat inzwischen eine Reisewarnung für
Israel herausgegeben die Luftwaffe flog
heute mit mehreren Maschinen 162
Menschen nach Hannover aus für die
Palästinenser im Gazastreifen unter
Raketenbeschuss ein unerreichbares Ziel
sie müssen mit der Not im abgesperrten
Gebiet zurechtkmen ohne auswieg auch wer
einen ausländischen Pass hat wie diese
Ukrainisch palästinens Familie sitzt
fest die Grenze nach Ägypten in Raffa
bleibt
geschlossen vorgestern wurde uns gesagt
wir sollen an die Grenze für die
Ausreise als wir ankamen gab es einen
Angriff wir mussten wieder weg gestern
sind wir wiederher vergeblich und heute
dasselbe Rafa wieder für
Hilfslieferungen öffnen ein Thema von US
Außenminister Blinken auf seiner
krisenmission bei arabischen Partnern
Ägyptens Sicherheit sei die rote Linie
so sagt Präsident alsisi der Israels
Angriffe kritisierte auch blinken
mahnte israel muss bei seiner Antwort
auf die Terrorangriffe unsere
gemeinsamen Werte beachten den Respekt
für das Leben und die menschliche Würde
und alles unternehmen um zivile Opfer zu
vermeiden morgen wird blinken wieder in
Israel erwartet im Mittelpunkt vor allem
die Sorge vor einer Ausweitung des
Konflikts wie berechtigt diese Sorge ist
das machte Irans Außenminister Amir
abdullahan heute in Katar dass der Hamas
n steht deutlich zusammen mit Hamas Chef
han warnte er Israel vor einer weiteren
Eskalation alle Parteien hätten die
Finger am Abzug so Irans Chefdiplomat
was das heißt war an der
israelischlibanesischen Grenze zu
beobachten Libanons terrormiliz hisbolla
und israelische atillerie feuerten
aufeinander es gab mehrere
Tote wir haben kein Interesse an einem
Krieg im Norden wir wollen die Situation
nicht eskalieren aber wenn jemand hier
Fehler macht dann wird er dafür einen
Preis
zahen die Nervosität
steigt das Böse ein Übel bekämpfen das
Problem dabei ist nur niemand weiß wie
das gehen soll ohne neues Übel zu
schaffen ehut Barak war Teil von
hochbrisanten
mossataktionen er war Kommandeur deret
matkal Eliteeinheit der Israel Armee er
war Generalstabschef natürlich
Premierminister und ist jetzt bei uns
der am höchsten dekorierte Soldat
Israels good evening
Barak würden sie jetzt in Netanyahus
Haut stecken
wollen ich beneide ihn nicht und ich
möchte auch nicht spekulieren deswegen
kann ich das nicht beantworten dann was
meinen Sie denn wie muss diese Operation
die jetzt ja offenbar bevorsteht ganz
konkret
aussehen
am liebsten würden wir natürlich unsere
Ziele durch reine Luftangriffe durch
Bombardierungen erreichen das ist aber
unmöglich ziel ist es
sicherzustellen dass wir jedwede
operative Fähigkeit von Hamas Lehmen und
dass diese brutalen Mord und
barbarischen Angriffe nie mehr passieren
können das heißt wir brauchen dafür
bodentrucken und das könnte den nächsten
Tagen passieren und wie lange wird dies
ihrer Meinung nach anhalten müssen bis
ein das Ziel erreicht ist dass die
Regierung ausgegeben hat nämlich Hamas
zu
vernichten na ja wir sind im Krieg man
kann nicht genau vorher sagen wie lange
das dauert zwei Seiten sind beteiligt
das ist ein echter Krieg das dauert
vielleicht mehrere Wochen oder ein paar
Monate das ist unvorhersehbar aber wir
sind entschlossen Hamas
auszulöschen als militärische Kraft und
hoffentlich auch als politische Kraft im
Gazastreifen Herr Barack sie waren
Kommandeur ein Kommandeur von
israelischen Streitkräften im Ersten
Libanonkrieg das war ein Krieg der sehr
lange dauerte und am Ende Chaos
hinterlassen hat im Libanon und auch
wieder mehr Krieg israel hat jetzt
gerade in der Vergangenheit gerade eben
sehr sehr viel Leid erfahren und bringt
jetzt aber auch leid für die
Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza wie kann dieser
ja dieser Teufelskreis gestoppt werden
und müsste man ihn nicht auch irgendwann
stoppen
zunächstm kann man diese zwei Dinge
nicht vergleichen scheint eine
moralische Äquivalenz zu geben aber das
stimmt nicht so einen barbarischen
Angriff hat es noch nie gegeben in der
Geschichte Israels das war der
schlimmste Schlag den das Land je
erlitten hat das Äquivalent also nur von
den Toten her betrachtet die 1300
Menschen vor allen Dingen Zivilisten die
umkamen die massakriert wurden das wäre
wenn 100000 deutsche wahrscheinlich mehr
als das getötet worden
wären das war also ein schlimmer Schlag
in 24 Stunden man kann das nicht
vergleichen es stimmt wir halten uns an
das Völkerrecht aber jeder der weiß dass
in seiner
Nachbarschaft oder an seinem
Arbeitsplatz irgendwelche Aktivitäten
waren heute oder Vergangenheit letzten
zwei Jahren der muss wissen er wird zum
Ziel er sollte sich aber Herr Barack wir
reden über 1,1 Millionen Menschen wir
reden auch über alte über Menschen die
sich gar nicht fortbewegen können die
krank
sind die die sich selber nicht bewegen
können die sollten an einen sicheren Ort
gebracht werden durch die UNO oder die
NGOs aber 1,1 Millionen Menschen wir
haben gehört in den ersten 36 Stunden
sind schon eine halbe Million
weggegangen und hoffentlich bleiben noch
24 Stunden und die G Million sich wegeg
haben die die nicht gehen risieren ihr
Leben das ist ganz klar ist schmerzhaft
aber das ist die Realität es ist ein
Krieg gegen eine barbarische Gruppe wie
alqida oder der
is und die sollte ausgelöscht werden und
danach werden wir dann Frieden
bekommen jetzt ist nicht die Zeit um
über den Frieden zu sprechen ich habe
lange Zeit als Politiker über Frieden
gesprochen das ist nicht auf dem Tisch
zunächst müssen wir den Krieg gewinnen
wenn wir den Krieg nicht gewinnen gibt
es keinen Frieden wenn wir den Krieg
gewinnen gibt es eine neue Chance ein
neues Kapitel aufzuschlagen aber wir
werden gewinnen und wir werden die
militärischen Fähigkeiten von Hamas
auslöschen egal was nötig ist sagt eh
Barak ehemaliger Premierminister des
Staates Israel Barak vielen Dank für das
Gespräch thank you very
much und aus Gaza heute ein Treck des
Elends und der Angst Israels Armee hat
alle im Norden des schmalen
Küstenstreifens ultimativ aufgefordert
ihre Wohnungen zu räumen eine
Massenflucht für über eine Million
Menschen es ist schwer Menschen in Gaza
zu erreichen da auch Telefon und
Internet nicht mehr richtig
funktionieren bislang schon die einzige
Verbindung für Gaza nach draußen es
spielt sich dort ein Drama ab und die
Welt bekommt höchstens Ausschnitte davon
mit ich habe vorhin mit dr hamis Elisi
gesprochen er ist Arzt für
Schmerztherapie in Gaza er praktiziert
dort auch am Krankenhaus und ich habe
ihn gefragt was können Ärzte wie sie in
dieser Situation noch für die Menschen
tun meine Hauptsorge galt bisher meinen
Krebspatienten aber jetzt geht es an
jetzter Stelle darum den Menschen mit
schlimmen akuten Schmerzen zu helfen
chronische Schmerzen haben jetzt nicht
die Priorität viel mehr versuchen wir
jetzt vor allem den Patienten mit akuten
Schmerzen zu
helfen haben sie denn überhaupt
Möglichkeiten und genug Ärzte um da
jetzt ausreichend Hilfe leisten zu
können wir haben viele Patienten mit
Herzkrankheiten viele Krebspatienten die
ihre Chemotherapie und ihr
Behandlungsschema brauchen und im Moment
nicht bekommen können abgesehen von den
2400 Toten infolge der Kampfhandlungen
gibt es aber aber tausende von Menschen
die Gefahr laufen zu sterben aber
indirekt nicht durch die Kriegshandlung
selbst viel mehr sind diese Menschen
nicht in der Lage die medizinische
Versorgung zu erhalten die Sie benötigen
wenn sie nicht sterben wollen das sind
Patienten mit Nierenversagen Patienten
mit Herzleiden und Krebspatienten und
ich schicke diese Botschaft und diesen
Aufruf an alle Verantwortlichen im
Ausland handeln Sie jetzt denn es
sterben hunderte von Menschen jeden
Tag sie selbst sind mittlerweile viermal
von einem Ort zum anderen geflohen
innerhalb des Gazastreifens jetzt sind
sie wieder zurück in Ihrem Zuhause im
Norden von Gaza obwohl Israels Armee
eigentlich alle aufgefordert hatte von
dort zu gehen warum tun sie das nicht
man kann nirgendwohin hier geht es nicht
um mich hier geht es um 2,3 Millionen
Menschen in Gaza es leben allein 1,3
Millionen Menschen im nördlichen Teil
wie soll man 1,3 Millionen Menschen
evakuieren erinnern sie sich noch als
man die Ukrainer evakuierte sie haben
jeden Tag 40 50 000 Menschen evakuiert
wie soll man den 1,3 Millionen Menschen
evakuieren als sie sich auf den Weg
machten wurden viele von ihnen
beschossen und starben unterwegs als sie
in der albala oder in hananunis ankam
starben sie dort in den Häusern oder auf
den Straßen und es werden noch mehr
sterben dr hamis elissi aus dem Norden
des Gazastreifens erschildert die Lage
der Menschen dort insbesondere der
Kranken und Verletzten das Gespräch
haben wir aus technischen Gründen vor
der Sendung
aufgezeichnet Kampf gegen Hamas die
Bemühungen die verschleppten Menschen
zurückzubekommen das steht bei den
Israelis hier im Vordergrund aber dann
kommt egal mit wem man hier spricht die
Frage nach dem Versagen der eigenen
Regierung wie konnte es überhaupt soweit
kommen der Staat Israel hat seinen
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern immer ein
Versprechen gemacht dass Sie hier sicher
sind dieses Versprechen ist jetzt
gebrochen es ist still in dieser Stadt
die doch eigentlich niemals schlafen
wollte
schenkinstraße Tel Aviv eine
Geisterstadt hier um die Ecke habe ich 5
Jahre lang als nahostkorrespondent
gelebt und so etwas nie zuvor gesehen
das hier ist das Zentrum der
lebenslustigsten Metropole am Mittelmeer
normalerweise würden hier hunderte auf
der Straße stehen und das Leben feiern
und jetzt ist ganz
es ist der Schock nach der Terrorattacke
von Hamas und vielleicht auch die Ruhe
vor dem Sturm nach ausgehen ist
niemandem
zumute wir hatten schon viele Bomben
hier von Hamas aber sowas noch nie ich
habe eine Großmutter die den Holocaust
überlebt hat ich kenne ihre Geschichten
ich habe so etwas noch nie
erlebt geschlossene Geschäfte deren
Inhaber sich
das so noch weitergehen kann auch
wirtschaftlich nur der Weinladen läuft
hier verkaufen sie
Ablenkung um ehrlich zu sein eine Menge
Leute kaufen Alkohol Wodka Bier die
ganze Woche
schon Szenen einer Stadt in größter
Sorge ein Land in dem man überall
Menschen trifft die direk betroffen
sind die auf
einben ihren Töchtern Brüdern Müttern
Vätern die Romans bangen um drei
Mitglieder ihrer Familie die verschleppt
wurden nach
Gaza nicht hier in Israel nein das ist
ein totalchock für uns
und ich weiß nicht wie es weiter weiter
gehen von hier weil das ist ein
echt ich weiß nicht
ja so viele offenen Fragen so viewis ze
jeden Tag
neu immer wieder Deckung suchen auch in
Tel Aviv immer wieder
Alarm ins geheime habe ich schon
manchmal den Gedanken gewagt dass die
Palästinenser und wir vielleicht nicht
genug gelitten haben Tom Segev ist einer
der renommiertesten Historiker dieses
Landes das Versprechen von Sicherheit
war immer zentral für Israel ich weiß
nicht ob es für immer bleibt aber es
begleitet uns sicher sehr viele Jahre
dieses Gefühl die Notwendigkeit alles
neu zu überlegen
Wahrheiten an die wir
glaubten haben sich als Fantasie auch
rausgestellt es ist viel zerstört in den
Seelen der Menschen hier und es ist noch
nicht
vorbei unser Israel Korrespondent
michaelunge ist natürlich heute Abend
mit dabei Michael guten Abend guten
Abend wir haben gerade Tom seggef den
großen Historiker gehört und seine Worte
gehen mir wirklich nicht mehr aus dem
Kopf er hat gesagt wir sind nicht so
stark wie wir dachten hier in Israel und
er sagt auch man wird jetzt alles neu
bedenken müssen er sagt sogar wir werden
unsere Identität neu formulieren kann
man jetzt schon sagen wo dieses Land
Israel in einigen Wochen stehen
wird also was man mit Sicherheit sagen
kann ist dass es eine gnadenlose
Abrechnung eine knalerte Rechnung mit
dem Versagen der Regierung geben wird in
Umfragen sagen
86% dass die Schuld an diesem Massaker
bei der Regierung zu suchen ist weil sie
versagt hat und sogar 80% der Anhänger
dieser Regierung sagen dass die Schuld
bei der Regierung liegt eine Mehrheit
sagt Netanyahu muss zurücktreten und
Netanyahu könnte das gleiche Schicksal
drohen wie goldam Meir 1974 ein Jahr
nach dem jomkipur Krieg wo Israel
ebenfalls überrasch Angriffen war sie
musste da zurücktreten
zu hoffen wäre vielleicht dürfen wir ja
Korrespondenten auch mal Wünsche äußern
dass dieser Konflikt wie Tom seggef das
sagt zu völlig neu politisch gedacht
wird dass man eben nicht nur nach neuen
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen nachdenkt und spürt
was wird sicherlich auch passieren wird
sondern fragt wie können denn nach
vielleicht einer langen blutigen
Schlacht und nach Beseitigung der
Drohung durch die Hamas
Ansätze geschaffen werden gar nicht zwei
stenlösung aber eine neue Ansätze
geschaffen werden wo zwei Entitäten
aufinander zugehen zugestehen etwas
abgehen aber auch beide etwas zugewinnen
können natürlich dürfen Korrespondenten
Hoffnung haben Michael auf jeden Fall
jetzt vielleicht noch ganz aktuell zum
Schluss mit der Bitte um eine kurze
Antwort egal mit wem man hier spricht
jeder Taxifahrer erzählt einem heute
Nacht könnte es losgehen wie sieht
tatsächlich aus was wie sieht jetzt der
Zeitplan aus was kann man darüber sagen
also es gibtele Spekulation aucht um die
Bodenoffensive genau es gibt viele
Spekulationen die Bodenoffensive auch
dass das Wetter eine Rolle spielen könne
und dass das deswegen erstmal verschoben
wäre das kann sein das kann auch nicht
sein es kann sein dass Israel nur noch
mehr Zeit haben wollte für die
Evakuierung von Gaza
und dabei nicht das Gesicht verlieren
wollte aufs Wetter geschoben hat es kann
auch sein dass Israel schlicht die Hamas
täuschen will und die Offensive
jederzeit Vorgehen
starten kann Israel hat das schon einmal
gemacht vor zwe Jahren ich würde sagen
Israel ist vorbereitet für diese
Offensive sie kann jederzeit losgehen
man wird es merken weil es wird ein
starkes vorbereitendes Bombardement von
Gaza City geben Michael Bewerung unser
ZDF Israel kpent vielen dank Michael
danke
dir ja es brennt sich gerade für einen
deutschen hier ins Gedächtnis ein wie
oft die Israelis im Moment die eigene
Situation in Bezug setzen zum Holocaust
Etti Hillesum eine junge Jüdin schrieb
vor ihrer Ermordung im KZ in ihr
Tagebuch eines Tages werden wir eine
ganz neue Welt aufbauen gegen jede neue
Schandtat und jeden neuen Schrecken
werden wir ein weiteres Stück Liebe und
Güte errichten wir können leiden aber
wir dürfen nicht aufgeben Shalom und
salam und einen guten Abend aus Israel
Anne danke Christian für diese Eindrücke
aus Tel
Aviv und wir schauen jetzt nach Polen so
richtig geglaubt hat keiner aber nach
ersten Prognosen hat die
europafreundliche Opposition die
Parlamentswahl gewonnen und das obwohl
der Wahlkampf in Polen eine
Schlammschlacht war die regierende
nationalpopulistische peaceepartei mit
parteichf jaroswav katinski an der
Spitze zog alle Register um den
Kandidaten der Opposition
exregierungschef Donald Tusk mit Dreck
zu bewerfen die Regierungspartei
beschuldigte den Konkurrenten Tusk ein
Agent moskausest estens aber der
deutschen und ganz sicher einer der EU
zu sein aber offenbar hat diese Kampagne
nicht verfangen Polen hat den Wechsel
gewählt Polen hat für Europa gestimmt
Andreas küast berichtet aus
Warschau ich bin sehr stolz auf euch und
ich bin der glücklichste Mann der Welt
vor einer Stunde steht Ronald Tusk vor
seinen Anhängern in Warschau und sieht
etwas das er Jahre lang nicht gesehen
hat lachende glückliche Gesichter seiner
Bürgerplattform
Hoffnung jarosw jaroswav vor einer
Stunde steht jaroswav Kinski vor seinen
Anhängern in Warschau und muss etwas
sagen dass er 8 Jahre lang nicht gesagt
hat die Frage ist ob es möglich sein
wird unseren Erfolg in eine weitere
Amtszeit uns Regierung zu
verwand Donald Tusk liegt auf Platz aber
die Chance eine Koalition zu bilden die
Überraschung nach einem Wahlkampf der
endlos hemmungslos und aggressiv war
dass die Opposition im
öffentlichrechtlichen Fernsehen als die
proeutsche Mission Tusks bezeichnet
wurde dass er nur einmal in 8 Jahren
persönlich etwas sagen durfte hielt Tusk
dem Sender vor Ort
vor die Propaganda die in dieser
lügenfabrik hergestellt wird sagte Tusk
vor der tvpzentrale in Warschau aber
weiter kam er nicht haben sie das mit
Frau Merkel abgesprochen unterbrach
einer der bekanntesten TVP Moderatoren
den Kandidaten Tumult geschupse ein
normaler Tag im polnischen
Wahlkampf heute am Wahltag werden
Rekorde gebrochen die Wahlbeteiligung in
Warschau in bresslau in Stettin so hoch
wie noch nie und selbst in der Berliner
Luft liegt polnischechel Stimmung das
ist die Schlange vor einem der sieben
Wahllokale für die in Deutschland
lebenden
Polen ich bin zuversichtlich dass unser
Ergebnis sehr hoch sein
wird sagt Donald Tusk als er sich in
Warschau in sein Wahllokal kämpft da
dürfte der Chef der Bürgerplattform
bereits ahnen dass eine drei
parteienkoalition mit dem Linksbündnis
und dem konservativen dritten Weg in
Reichweite kommt jarossk wird zunächst
gar nicht bemerkt der mächtigste Mann
Polens der Chef der rechtsnationalen
Regierungspartei peace ist schweigend
gekommen und wird schweigend gehen einer
der ersten Tage seit langem an denen er
nicht schimpft über Tusk den
Befehlsempfänger der deutschen und über
die Deutschen die Befehlsempfänger der
Russen durchaus mit
Erfolg guten Tag deutsches Fernsehen wen
haben Sie
gewählt nicht den den ihr gerne wählt
ich habe für Tusk gestimmt ich finde ihn
sympathisch nett
einfühlsam am Abend tanzt die
Bürgerplattform nach zwei Wahlperioden P
hat die Partei von Donald Tusk eine
Chance auf die Macht Polen hat den
Wechsel
gewählt und darüber wollen wir reden mit
unserer Korrespondentin in Warschau
Natalie Steger vor dem polnischen
Parlament natie was bedeuten dies zahlen
jetzt die peace ist stärkste Partei
kriegt aber keine Mehrheit zusammen das
heißt ein Machtwechsel ist möglich
oder ja ein Machtwechsel ist möglich
auch sogar wahrscheinlich aber noch
nicht garantiert denn das wird jetzt
vermutlich so ablaufen weil die Pace die
Nummer 1 ist in den Wahlen wird
Staatspräsident duda ihr die
Regierungsbildung sie mit ihr sie damit
beauftragen also vermutlich morwiki der
muss dann verzweifelt versuchen stand
jetzt mindestens 31 Abgeordnete aus der
Opposition rüber zu sich zu ziehen das
ist ein sehr dickes Brett schafft er das
nicht dann wird ja in gewisser Zeit der
je Vertrauensfrage verlieren im same und
dann wird das Parlament wiederum
vermutlich Donald Tusk beauftragen mit
der Regierungsbildung und wir haben sie
im Beitrag gehört auch heute Abend haben
sie bestätigt die Linke und auch ein
weiteres christdemokratisches Bündnis
haben gesagt wir stehen zusammen wir
machen das und dann würde tatsächlich
Donald Tusk der ministerpr Präsident
eine kinke gibt es noch und katinski war
schon noch ein bisschen
kämpferisch man könnte tatsächlich die
peace könnte versuchen diese Wahlen die
Gültigkeit juristisch anzufechten also
ich schließe auch das nicht aus und wenn
Donald Tusk aber trotzdem eine Koalition
zusammen bekäme was würde das für das
Verhältnis zu Deutschland und vor allem
zur EU zu Europa
bedeuten na das würde beide Verhältnisse
schlagartig verbessern denn das
Verhältnis zu Deutschland das
deutschpolnisch das war wirklich nach
diesen 8 Jahren pace so schlecht wie
noch nie es ist so schlecht wie noch nie
zuletzt z.B bei ministerbesuchen aus
Berlin da gab's nicht mal zum Teil
gemeinsame presseaftritte weil der
peacevertreter dann sagt ich habe
einfach keine Zeit und natürlich haben
die reparationsfderungen die Warschau
offiziell fordert von Berlin dieses
Verhältnis massiv belastet und auch
dieser Wahlkampf also das würde sich
sicherlich ändern und auch in Brüssel
dürfte man aufgeatmet haben denn es
laufen ja einige
Vertragsverletzungsverfahren wegen
dieser sehr umstrittenen Justizreformen
in Polen Donald Tusk hat angekündigt
dass er diese politische Vereinnahmung
der Gerichte allen voran des
Verfassungsgerichts wieder zurückdrehen
will also das dürfte Entspannung bringen
bei einer Sache dürfte sich nicht
besonders viel ändern nämlich bei der
Migrationspolitik Tusk hat gesagt wenn
er Ministerpräsident wird auch er ist
gegen die zwangsum Umverteilung von
Flüchtlingen aber eins ist ganz klar er
wäre der kompromissbereitere und der
verlässlicher und der deutlich einfache
Verhandlungspartner für Brüssel danke
Natalie für die Interpretation der
Zahlen Natalie Steger war das aus
Warschau und wir machen hier weiter mit
weiteren wichtigen Nachrichten und mit
Hanna Zimmermann im wen Afghanistans hat
es am Morgen erneut ein schweres
Erdbeben gegeben laut US-Angaben hatte
es eine Stärke von 6,3 mindestens zwei
Menschen sollen ums Leben gekommen sein
zudem ist von etwa 150 Verletzten die
Rede die Zahlen könnten allerdings noch
steigen da einige betroffene Gebiete
sehr entlegen sind bei den verheerenden
Beben am vergangenen Wochenende starben
in der Region mehr als 1000 Menschen
bereits am Mittwoch hatte es ein starkes
Nachbeben
gegeben angesichts der Eskalation in
narost hat der ukrainische Präsident
selenski betont dass die Hilfen für die
Ukraine nicht nachlassen dürften auch an
diesem Wochenende gab es nach
ukrainischen Angaben mehrere Tote durch
russische Angriffe so soll und sollen
unter anderem im Gebiet hakiv in der
Ostukraine zwei Menschen getötet worden
sein russlands Präsident Putin erklärte
unterdessen dass sich die Lage der
russischen Streitkräfte an der Front
verbessert
habe zum Start der Woche der
Welthungerhilfe hat Bundespräsident
Steinmeier in einer Fernsehansprache
dazu aufgerufen die Hilfsorganisation zu
unterstützen noch immer hungerten etwa
735 Millionen Menschen weltweit sagte
steinme betroffen seien vor allem Kinder
und Jugendliche der Klimawandel
verschärfe die Lage dramatisch der
Bundespräsident ist Schirmherr der
Hilfsorganisation in Berlin hat es trotz
eines Demonstrationsverbots am
Nachmittag erneut eine
proalästinensische Kundgebung gegeben
etwa 1000 Menschen versammelten sich
laut Polizei auf dem potsdammer Platz
undund 500 Einsatzkräfte waren vor Ort
und forderten die Demonstrierenden auf
die Versammlung zu beenden dabei kam es
zum Teil zu rangeleinen zwischen
Protestierenden und
Polizei bei der Ironman WM der Frauen
auf Hawaii haben die Deutschen
profiriathletinnen Anne Haug und Laura
Philipp Silber und Bronze gewonnen die
40-Jährige Haug kam nach knapp ateinhalb
Stunden als Zweite ins Ziel es ist
bereits ihre fünfte wmmaille mit Platz 3
machten machte dann Philip das erste
deutsche doppelpodest bei den perfekt
Gold gewann die Britin Lucy Charles
barleay mit
Streckenrekord und jetzt der Blick auf
die herbstlichen
Wetteraussichten morgen gibt es im
Norden viele Wolken und vereinzelt etwas
Regen an der Ostsee und im Süden zeigt
sich dagegen häufig die Sonne bei 8 bis
15° die nächsten Tage sind herbstlich
und zunächst meist trocken am Mittwoch
und Donnerstag zieht von Südwest nach
Nordost Regen über uns hinweg dann lebt
auch der Wind auf bei 9 bis
18° und hier geht's jetzt weiter mit
einer neuen schwedischen krimmiserie
Detectiv Nummer 24 und einem ganz
besonderen
ermittlerdo und morgen erwartet Sie hier
das bewrt du aus Marietta Slomka und
Heinz Wolf und die nächsten Nachrichten
gibt's hier gegen 0:25 Uhr mit Mark
Burgemeister Ihnen einen guten Start in
die Woche tschüss
tschüss